[Music]
okay now we're here on overtime Rachel
in your recent reddit ask me anything
you confess to having gun enthusiasm
what's up with that I enjoy shooting
guns recreationally and so I gun ranges
and stuff my first date with Susan was
at a gun range her sister's a lifetime
and are a member and she was hosting
ladies day on the range yes and our
first date was shooting all sorts of
stuff I just don't think you should be
able to bring all that stuff home and
what good is it I don't enjoy shooting
out other people I enjoy shooting at
targets well no one enjoys shoot well
that's well some people do enjoy shoot
yeah but you know I mean it's funny I
hear you say that because you know
liberals are sometimes mad at me for
saying that I am NOT going to
unilaterally disarm in a country full of
gun nuts
I don't enjoy having a gun I compare it
to antibiotics they say you know I have
a gun like I have antibiotics I hope I
never have to use it but I don't love my
antibiotic but is your gun Hollis my
amoxicillin Michele hoo hoo but but
you're gonna post a background check or
registering absolutely not do all these
things but it's all [ __ ] you know
that too because we don't have an
anti-gun party in this country the
Democrats love guns do although we had
an assault weapons ban from 1994 to 2004
that would have made it so the kid who
shot up Sandy Hook elementary that he
got those weapons from his mom his mom
got them legally good enough for today
okay but that but it didn't get extended
because of you but that kid would have
brought one of the
he was Republican beat with the Persian
president supported the president's
support but that did what the Democratic
Senate does this year on the guns well
right now the Democrats in the Judiciary
Committee just passed background
tractors past the assault weapons ban
and all of these things have the law
stayed in effect for after 2004 and had
the Republican Congress and George Bush
not killed it then she would not have
been able to legally buy the 30-round
magazines he used or the air fear then
he would have brought one of the other
2,000 guns available in America that the
Democrats loved he fought a hundred he
fired a hundred and fifty two bullets in
less than five minutes yeah he had great
load 15 times instead of four times he
would not have been able to fire 150
bullets before he lost thank you
absolutely great the bill you're right
he switched my parades I'm officer I'm
all for that bad but if you think it
really accomplishes a lot you're kidding
it did a kick you can't there's no
you're kidding knows perfect in gun
rules but there are better rules than
others I have an idea yeah there are
great I want for passing it alright
here's my idea and and I don't think the
technology is there yet but I just
wonder if somebody who's listening could
develop this you have you put a chip in
every gun and there are certain places
where that chip shuts off that guns
functioning so for example in a school
and I don't know that the technology is
that it's not here yet but I know that's
that far away and that strikes me as a
good solution you have all the guns you
want but they're they're essentially
going to be dysfunctional when you take
them in to say a school or an airport or
an airplane
well greatly have fewer gun owners but
you have more guns than you'd ever hear
what you're doing you got more guns for
guns is weird better yeah look we got
300 million guns but for Americans
owning them which means that people are
setting awesome it's the gun right
that's the gun nuts yeah you know I mean
look there people who electors many
people connected I mean to me the
difference is you know if you want to
have your picture taken with your gun
you're not okay I have a gun I've never
taken a picture of like is my gun
Rachael any pictures with your gun never
I don't own a gun
I just don't do guy shot guns at ranges
and stuff but no I did shoot a tank in
Iraq once you shot it I got fake and I
hit the trigger and a big thing flew out
of the tank and wow that was five
thousand dollars and then I felt very
bad
exactly take bullets are really okay
well you know speaking of this I wanted
to mention this on the show we run at a
time but the knives on planes issue I
kind of burned me because I thought the
TSA actually made the right call in one
of those situations where I saw both the
left and the right agree this is so
stupid
how can they say that we can't bring
water on a plane but we can bring a
knife because the TSA actually studies
this issue and you actually can bring
down a plane if you brought on a water
bottle but it really was something other
than water but now that we've reinforced
the cockpit doors and there's probably
of air marshal on the plane they're not
going to bring down the plane as an
international dude
we're just conforming to what other
countries are doing international so
you're okay with knives on planes I am
okay with knives on really III I'm not I
just I don't have any particularly good
rationale other than I don't want a
bunch of people with knives why do you
need a knife on a plane you're gonna
you're gonna cut some you know it it's a
little cream cheese good guy with the
nail no Jared you know you don't need it
on the plane most people on the plane
are traveling so put it away suitcase
put it I don't like I don't like to
check luggage it takes a long time they
lose it yada yada I mean you know it's a
way to give us back a little bit of just
the normal life that we're all
complaining it's also is doing it
because if there's a knife in the
luggage in the carry-on it slows
everything down and so it right speed up
the speed of the process but you know
taking a little knife and it can't be a
locking knife can't be a locking but a
thief only knife you can react or screw
on now before you couldn't so it's this
is common sense I think it's a smart
thing to do
okay well the use of drones be one of
President Obama's lasting legacies maybe
even overshadowing health care reform no
I don't think about I don't know about
that but I mean well we need some sort
of calls and procedures right now I
think that drone volute Lee I think
people need to know well under what
conditions are going to use them is
there any kind of judicial overview
after the fact you can't just have a
government using these things
willy-nilly did you have that position
under Bush I hear what they were
and more using drones under but not the
other word not to the extent not to the
know Obama has upped it but they were
certainly doesn't make sense in a
warfare but they were certain no but
wait they were using them under Bush I
had that position you did yeah
absolutely
here's one thing I think is important
about the drone thing is that we're
using the CIA as if the CIA is the
military right and the downside of that
is that the way the CIA operates under
precedent and laws that if you ask an
elected official how about this thing
the CIA did they can deny that it ever
happened well then how do we have
accountability for this more that we're
fighting with the CIA oh there should be
under the military not over the CIA we
have 15 spy agencies we have a budget
for the defense that nobody could ever
imagine
one thing Eisenhower got so right was
that [ __ ] about you know the
military-industrial complex are gonna
take over this country boy no prediction
I feel like in politics ever was more on
the money he was general so he saw it
coming you see more yeah okay thank you
everybody Thank You panel Thank You
audience your philippic I'll see you
next week
little time we do it more exciting idea
tuna
villains guests or questions right after
the show at hbo.com